[Musique]
lee
salut les terriens salut les terriens
bienvenue dans votre top du samedi soir
bonsoir
avec 2 ce soir 3 therrien de choix
victoria abril
[Applaudissements]
à l'aller à victorien yo soy mucho
contento d'intérêt voire yachts et 500
millions à 1 pas mon ça n'a plus rien
d'un sol des croustades affectionne
alors je me suis un espagnol
autres terrienne invité ce soir béatrice
martin
autres terriens d'inviter ce soit coeur
de pirate
[Applaudissements]
est ce que je peux lui appelé coeur de
maintenance
d'habitants
[Applaudissements]
j'ai découvert en préparant cette
émission que vous étiez pieds noirs vous
savez que les gens vont tomber sur le
cul en apprenant simple que d'habitude
et pieds-noirs ça se voit à quoi il part
avec les marins temps forts mais vous
alors rien quoi écouter effectivement il
ya plusieurs années que je dire aux gens
qu effectivement chauvinois
que dire en vérité en p3 après que je
zappe in et stéphane guillon nous
accueillons notre terrienne du samedi 20
heures ce soir la femme la plus menacée
de france la journaliste de charlie
hebdo zineb el rhazoui
voilà l'émission s'appelle salue les
câlins et le groupe est vraiment
fortiche
et maintenant voici mon stagiaire tom
ville
[Musique]
et là qu'est ce qui t'a appris de mettre
nolwenn lent mais ce n'est pas la
chanteuse préfère vincent bolloré non
vincent bolloré shannon steven du monde
c'est pavano
comment ça va diriger vers un bon soir
je pense que bon on va faire un petit
débrief de l'émission de la semaine
dernière sur twitter les gens trouvent
que vous avez trop forcer avec la promo
de pattaya le film mais c'est sûr ça
fait trois fois je vous ai prévenus ou
papier rires et je sais non mais
vraiment fait faut y aller mollo il faut
que je règle n a pas bougé lyon et pas
un truc
ouais
mais c'est que normalement ouais c'était
des cendres de pascal sevran taoui balas
et c'est jean pierre coffe alors
il faut être discret thierry vous serez
un moment je jure ça va ça va se voir
tout simplement voilà donc qu'est ce que
je vais dire
très très beau plateau ce soir thierry
voilà c'est ça beaucoup de diversité à
une québécoise une espagnole un pied
noir c'est on est à l'onu tout
simplement
victoria abril bonsoir en victoria c'est
la grande star franco espagnole avec
avec julio iglesias et la crise
financière et non alors ça ne l'est pas
nous voir souvent quand vous venez il ya
de la promo alors là on va tout faire la
série clem sur tf1 oui il ya un film en
espagne à 6 d'apparat ghana oui voilà et
puis votre prix victoire qui regroupe
tout l'ensemble de votre carrière donc
si vous avez une bagnole à vendre c'est
maintenant n'hésitez pas
en tout cas je vous qu'auriez-vous
cartonné sur tf1 avec la série clem et
d'ailleurs j'ai découvert vous mesure 1
mètre 57 105 ans et non 63 63
ahmed 60 à 25 centimètres près ce
n'était pas la même série ou juillet sur
tf1 vous auriez jouer un ange qui claque
des doigts
même si c'est vrai je me méfie avec
victoria parce que je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez il ya quelques années elle
avait l'avait giflé un journaliste qui
avait mal parlé d'un nouveau film qui
n'avait alors
amis habitant bonsoir
je l'aimé beaucoup mais j'aimerais ça
faire c'est un mec très très marrant bon
ce soir peut-être qu'il sera un peu
moins marrant que d'habitude parce que
le décor est pas pencher mais
ary abittan les visiteurs 3 ils
s'emmerdent plus il fait que des films
qui cartonnent et films à succès saari
en deux films 20 millions spectateurs 19
millions 8 qu'est ce qu'on a fait au bon
dieu et 200 milles avec robin des bois
c'est là où on voit que c'est un
excellent comédien a ri parce que il
joua marquis et voilà quand même passé
de coco ou malheur stéphane bern il
aurait pas fait la vérité si je mens
alors dans le film troie godefroy de
montmirail vous appelle les suit cul
voilà oui thierry m'a donné le même
surnom est pas pour les mêmes raisons en
titre
coeur de pirate à l'histoire mais
l'actrice alors béatrice martin vous
revenez avec un nouvel album et ça c'est
très bien il ya un an vous aviez fait
partie du projet la bande à renault il y
avait toute la jeune génération qui
reprenait les tubes de renault en buvant
du ricain ça c'était vraiment bien et
qu'ils avaient votre prise de mistral
gagnant qui m'avait beaucoup touché mais
ma chanson ma préféré passer votre tube
c'est comme des enfants c'est la chanson
préférée aussi du cardinal barbarin
non votre nouvel album s'appelle rose et
le single oublie moi alors faut faire
très attention ce que la rousseau avait
chanté tu m'oublieras et elle a déminé
creux voilà bien l'oublier
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
thierry ardisson n'a pas osé vous posez
victoria abril à victoria vous passez
votre temps entre la france et l'espagne
est-ce que vous en profiter pour faire
des go-fast pour parvenir à vide etc et
des gaufrettes des gaufrettes c'était
pour fred c'est un truc au chocolat
est-ce que tu prends une gaufrette au
chocolat pour traverser c'est un truc
spécial dessine
coeur de pirate pour terminer vous avez
repris mistral gagnant de renaud you
know i'm no good d'amy winehouse d'où
vous vient cette passion pour les
chanteurs alcoolique
c'est une bonne émission
si la semaine au 10 juillet au théâtre
apollo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois que ça c'est pour elle ça
ary abittan remonte ce soir
vous savez que vous êtes beau
vous êtes encore plus beau votre merlot
10 arrive franchement ça fait dix bonnes
gueules ary abittan mesdames messieurs
les dents les plus blanches du cinéma
français ary abittan prix fluocaril 2016
ou brosser les dents après chaque
réplique ou c'est parce que votre peau
est bronzée 15 août non parce qu'en fait
j'ai porté un appareil oui ça m'a aligné
mais dans donc ça fait que maintenant
j'ai suivi leur but et c'est très
agréable
alors oui vous êtes né le 31 janvier
1974 à paris
père d'origine tunisienne mère d'origine
marocaine exactement le contraire ah
ouais mon père d'origine marocaine et ma
mère d'origine norvégienne
non mais les gars vérifiez vos fiches
parce qu'il y avait il à 300 fiches pour
quatre lignes ça il faut le savoir c'est
important quand vous grandissez à
sarcelles est très jeune en fait c'est
déjà ce qu'on appelle une vedette en cm2
par exemple vous deviez apprendre par
coeur l'invitation au voyage de
baudelaire ne l'ait pas fait la
maîtresse vous engagez vous dites mais
laissez-moi lire le texte vous lisez le
texte vous fait un triomphe en fait non
exactement elle me demande de jouer ça
je les jouais et j'ai eu non seulement
une excellente note mais en plus de ça
j'ai réussi mon année parce que je me
suis dit l'école c'est pas pour moi
alors votre inspiration c'est votre
grand mère maternelle banques
tunisiennes qui ressemblait à madame
sarfati d'elie kakou quoi oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'elle avait cette voie
comme ça très fins et et puis surtout
elle faisait la macarena belle salle ça
ça ça c'est énorme c'est ce qu'elle
faisait en plus comme c acide de la
tomate elle mettait un peu de sucre
sucre lavalard vous mets pas tes dans la
bouche de tirer à 10 ans entendent
marque car on a beau faire
c'est mieux c'est mieux quand c'est
alors à 19 ans vous écrivez vos premiers
sketchs sept chauffeurs de taxi pour
payer vos cours de théâtre et vous aviez
un arbre magique accroché au rétroviseur
et des boules en bois d'enghien non
j'avais passage n'est pas fait longtemps
je vais par contre c'était vraiment un
vivier de personnages là j'ai beaucoup
appris et surtout j'enregistrais à
l'époque c'était les cassettes audio tu
sais j'ai enregistré mes sketches là
dessus et je les faisais écouter aux
passagers et je leur faisais croire que
c'était rire et chansons grain et ils
disaient qu'est ce qu'il est drôle ce
mec
dites moi désolé j'ai fini là où c'est
pas ma route ouais non mais maintenant
ils disent plus en maintenant il ya les
usa et tout ça tu rentres il te donne
une bouteille d'eau les shampoings 2 une
douche et 35 cents bon on dirait chez ma
mère non mais c'est extraordinaire non
me trouve ça formidable en tous les cas
cette histoire de chauffeurs de taxi
vous a permis de faire votre première
télé on regarde
pour gagner ce qu'on gagne et pour payer
ce qu'on paye et se faire buter
salma comme ça c'est horrible
parmi ces chauffeurs beaucoup ont déjà
été agressés ils savent que la nuit le
travail est bien plus dangereux alors
ils tentent de se protéger les familles
stocks la première est habitant
l'annoncé c'est un document exceptionnel
hors bilan c'est donc sur ses mains à
l'âge de 20 ans en 94 en 98 vous décidez
de vous auto produire un sarcelles vous
y êtes pour une soirée ça dure une
semaine et là vous être marqué par eddy
marouani edima royal
maroni l'imprésario de marlene dietrich
et de jacques brel exactement mario ce
timbre est complètement il était à la
fin de sa carrière il est mort six mois
il est mort c'est à dire qu'il m'a
découvert mais dit vous êtes formidable
on va travailler ensemble et tout ça et
c'est
bon c'est quand même bien mûri en moi et
j'espère que je vais vraiment je serai
toujours à la hauteur de ses espérances
parce qu'il a été très important pour
moi ensuite sur à gad elmaleh donc vous
fait des premières parties de de gad
elmaleh vous jouez dans le gym coco
évidemment arthur ça c'est pas du
travail c'est une barre minsk va où
écoutez c'est vrai que j'ai commencé à
parler de ma mère de mon père après j'ai
su évidemment est voulu et évoluer dans
le sens où effectivement j'ai beaucoup
parlé michèle var uc bras mathieu de la
comédie française jean michel bastos
dimitri d'un flot mairie cocagne lucien
lafage charlie boulot dodo michel valet
voilà oui évidemment en tout cas vous
êtes né sous une bonne étoile
certainement parce que c'est vrai que
c'est mes parents m'ont toujours
encouragé à faire ce métier là vous
faites qu'est ce qu'on a fait au bon
dieu aujourd'hui vous revenez avec les
visiteurs 3 de jean marie poiré avec
christian clavier jean reno franck du
boss alex lutz karin viard le pitch si
l'histoire de christian clavier qui est
re devenu bankable avec les profs et le
bon dieu et c'est le bon moment pour se
faire un max de thune avec le retour des
visiteurs
et en fait pas du tout parce que si vous
voulez vraiment se faire un max de thune
en vérité il l'aurait fait tout de suite
après sauf qu'il a attendu dix neuf ans
donc pourquoi il a attendu dix neuf ans
parce que pour faire un vrai film un
vrai film historique et la révolution
française à travers godefroy et jacques
bouille qui sont des personnages de
bande dessinée ils sont dans le coeur
des français et donc ce film ils sont à
table avec robespierre voilà toutes les
écoles doivent aller voir
mes chers
[Applaudissements]
alors dans le film que j'ai tourné un
sémillant débat ah ça ira ça ira ça ira
vous chantez essaouira essaouira riva
bella mais lola elle folle par ailleurs
oddo à quoi
tu t'appelles jacques couilles tu la
comté de l'acca de notre cousin
autrichien et c'est une plaie
moi c'est votre famille qui débarque un
grand colosse est un petit jeu lent qui
pue
les suprêmes couilles je suis
jacquouille la fripouille
on ne va pas de cette fouille ok
les gars points d'eau qui court dans la
baignoire du coup il est revenu pour
nous faire chier y'a pas d'ampoulés
électriques nuit jour jour/nuit médaille
à rien c'est niet ouamar hausse est de
la merde as royal
enfin bref il nous faut remettre le
dauphin sur son trône alors je ne veux
pas jouer les rabat joie que veux-tu les
sucs eu ce n'est pas gagné
mais d'une bombe
contre sochaux comptant ont pu la merde
robert on est à table
c'est un festival
kappeler la grosse course
si jamais ça dit ça de mamie
alain carré habitants qui notre invité
ce soir
alors ce sens le 6 avril juste une
question par rapport aux bronzés 3 c'est
comment
alors ça n'a rien à voir parce qu'il
s'agit des bronzés ne viennent pas et là
il s'agit des visites ah ouais c'est
complètement autre chose et je vous
assure thierry les gens sortent de ce
film tellement heureux et quoi qu'il
arrive godefroy et jacquouille ils sont
avec nous et on est heureux de les
retrouver on brille on déconne on est
joyeux livre la france et les blacks
[Applaudissements]
la paire 200 m on se retrouve sur terre
[Musique]
la mention à l'été à ermont soir était
un homme de retour choquant toujours en
compagnie de victoria abril
[Applaudissements]
coeur de pirate
et gary habitants
harry j'adore cette émission vu la
qualité de votre dentition on a envie de
vous voir rire avec quand vous voyez on
va vous 32 dont vous êtes le seul mec
alors vous savez que j'en ai 63 harris
et on sait et on va vers une interview
et ça vous fait rire
[Musique]
harry quel film vous fait rire le film
de ma circoncision ah ouais quoi
exactement je les reverrai ya pas
longtemps il c'est vrai que j'avais une
petite
cave émission de télé vous fait rien
téléfoot ah oui parce qu'ils en fait il
ya très peu d'image de foot dans
téléfoot parce que c'est pas parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les droits en fait et
il n'y a que des images de phu tho que
c'est plus d'émissions c'est un album
panini
[Applaudissements]
quel drame nous fait rire
le drame de la jalousie un film d'ettore
scola avec marcello mastroianni nos
syndicats péligry d'annoncer
qu'elle citation ouvrir j'aime bien une
citation qui dit que l'amour et
l'amour c'est ce que l'homme fait comme
effort pour se contenter que d'une seule
femme
cette crise cette situation c'est mon
oncle
[Applaudissements]
quel gros mouvements et ben c'est
toujours mon oncle quand il dit la
[__] tondu
quelle morgue vers et 1 il ya deux morts
que j'aime beaucoup c'est michael moore
et du lian
li
ah ah
et maintenant mesdames messieurs après
avoir triomphé au cinéma elle cartonne à
la télévision elle est au top
victoria abril
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
victoria abril ramon soir à monza 8on
qu'on s'est pas vu pour voir si depuis
vous avez progressé en france et je vais
vous poser une petite colle est ce qu'on
dit comment tout va ou comment tu vas
comment qui comment tu vas
[Applaudissements]
comme
jane birkin et calvario fait j'ai des
séjours linguistiques de plusieurs
années sans vraiment de résultats en
fait je me moque de votre accent mais
bien sûr c'est ce qui fait votre charme
vitoria vous le savez quand j'entends
votre accent j'ai envie de mettre un
costume moulant et de tuer et de tuer un
taureau avec une épée
[Musique]
et
le vent
j'adore / je
suis content alors victorien vous êtes
né à madrid le 4 juillet 1959 oui sous
le nom de victoria merida oui ensuite
vous prenez comme pseudo abril parce que
vous commencez à travailler au mois
d'avril
alors votre maire était fille de salle
dans un hôpital oui et votre père était
mort enfin c'est ce qu'on vous a raconté
un jour sur son lit de mort votre grand
mère lâche le morceau elle dit ton père
n'est pas mort il vit toujours il est
ingénieur à madrid et il est remarié
voilà donc victoria le monde cherche son
père avec vos soeurs et le jour où vous
le retrouver il est mort pour de vrai
oui
il vient de mourir ouais voilà des fois
il est mort deux fois alors vous obtenez
une photo de lui et vous n'osez pas le
regarder ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
que vous avez la photo que là et vous
avez un papier qui dézingue ans et vous
regardez déjà oui les cheveux comme moi
prix là le nez
pour moi il a la bouche comme massa
c'est terrible ce matin vous découvrez
votre père sur une toute petite faute au
fouet kg ça m'a pris une demi-heure à
découvrir petit à petit parce que tu
sais quand tu vois ton père d'amar quand
je vais voir normalement faire la vie
aux pontes habitué à sa gueule et à
l'aimer mais là quand ils les voient
ainsi comme ça d'un coup je dis il faut
qu' il faut que ça dure il faut que
j'aille petit à petit pour voir ses
couleurs sauver sa peau son feront
cesser ses sourcils ses yeux son nez qui
me ressemble alors à ce moment là vous
vous marier avec un homme qui a 15 ans
de plus que vous êtes 18 ans savait
d'arturo contre la volonté de votre
famille mais qui porte plainte pour
détournement de mineure ouais quel
crétin c'est à retour ou non oui et quel
crétin aussi ma mère pour bosser pour
s'être s'être
confronté à -17 façon parce que s'il
m'avait laissé tranquille je ne savais
pas marié enfin on aurait vécu ça va
durer ce que ça va durer et puis en fait
j'aime et son mari pour retrouver ma
liberté alors en retour vous l'aviez
croisé dans les couloirs de la
télévision près à l'époque où vous
présentiez une émission qui s'appelait
und au stress
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et aux guitares et b to b s'y
intéressent pas sa tasse avec une copie
cette escalade
[Applaudissements]
évidemment après ça sera très dur de
faire oublier cette émission aux gens de
cinéma évidemment parce que la
télévision a mauvaise image pourra pas
au cinéma alors c'est vrai qu'à prix
n'est pas qu'un peu difficile à un
moment vous êtes quand même l'assistante
d'un magicien au cirque américano oui
alors les colombes les foulards qui les
bras comme ça ça a duré comme une pensée
ça durait six mois le 3 janvier 1982
vous déménagez pour venir à paris par
amour pour gerard way qui est un
directeur photo oui et là vous faites
quelques films remarquables en fait j'ai
commencé le cinéma très jeune bien avant
parce que le mari de votre prof de danse
a été metteur en scène s'appelait pas
collard a et c'est avec lui que j'ai
fait obsession qui était votre premier
film à s'est ensuite richard lester
grand cinéaste anglais vit en espagne
pour faire la rose et la flèche vous
jouez avec lui tu fait aussi beaucoup de
films et vincente aranda comme
changement de sexe donc déjà fait
beaucoup de films en espagne quand vous
arrivez en france vous devenez ami avec
gérard jugnot et josiane balasko on fait
des films incroyables une époque
formidable casques bleus gaz on me dit
et puis à tous les films de pedro
almodovar attache-moi talons aiguilles
qui cas quelle carrière non
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui toria vous triomphez dans le
clem sur tf1 alors au départ c'était un
unitaire qui s'appelait clem maman trop
touristes sur une petite fille qui se
retrouve enceinte ça fait 10 millions de
téléspectateurs sur tf1 ils ont des
sillons dans une série évidemment
aujourd'hui ça fait en moyenne 7
millions c'est quand même énorme et le
prochain épisode l'ours et des thèmes
très très actuel le prochain épisode
c'est l'euthanasie c'est à dire qu
adrian votre fils de la
musique soit l'âge de 16 ans ont donné
en adoption appareils il annonce qu'il a
une tumeur au cerveau et qui veut se
faire automobile et donc ils démentent
des led et des manques de la compagnie
en suisse pour mourir est ce qui est
bien dans cet épisode c'est que ces deux
thèmes l'euthanasie et traitez pas d'un
point de vue pour ou contre c'est tout
les points de vue tous les points début
de toute la famille qui a évidemment un
avis sur la question mais c'est quand
même lui qui décide bon mais vous
angoissez pas il ya un truc que je
comprends pas est-ce que c'est réaliste
de vous appeler caroline boissier vous
fondez montmagny eyjafoll mais
maintenant que j'ai divorcé et qu'on va
peut-être se marier
n'est ce pas sans rappeler les mignonnes
ces
familles
coeur de pirate rebond soir
votre prénom
c'est béatrice martin mais c'est vrai
que béatrice martin ça fait un peu fi de
la compta ce jt
c'est ça fait pas pop star mondiale
éclatait alors quand on s'appelle
béatrice martin et qu'on veut se lancer
dans la chanson on commence par se
cherchait un nom de scène avant même
d'apprendre à jouer du piano ou une
angine en
avant la question que tout le monde se
pose en fait c'est pourquoi coeur de
pirate et packer de caribous
alors d'intégrer le conservatoire à
l'âge de 9 ans vous avez donné votre
premier concert dix ans plus tard à
l'âge de 19 ans aux francofolies de
montréal en première partie de benjamin
biolay un an plus tard fait l'olympia
c'est julien doré dont vous faites là
l'a pris à partie et là vous ont gardé
un souvenir absolument horrible 20
minutes dans l'indifférence générale
au moment où vous annoncer que c'est la
dernière chanson can't make up le deal
asselah d'evelyne c'est la déprime et là
mesdames messieurs le destin le destin
[Musique]
là ce qui se passe c'est que les
français adorent comme des enfants vous
pensez en vendre 1000
et puis un jour en allant faire vos
courses à monoprix vous entendez le truc
et vous vous dites ça y est quoi c'est
arrivé et vous allez en vendre 5 cent
cinquante mille exemples
alors oui moi c'est le clip du dernier
album puis nous avons choisi de vous
montrer
et oui moi
[Musique]
car si
et si
achètera
2 3
et
[Musique]
isabelle mois s'est extrait du dernier
album de coeur de pirate qui s'appelle
rose et à paris en ce moment c'est la
fin d'une tournée mondiale lorsque j'ai
remarqué en fait c'est qu'elle six
chansons en anglais est globalement
calmes et un son très radio américaine
vos ambitions se confirme en fait ça
commence j'ai commencé à faire de la
tournée aux états unis ça se passe bien
je trie way et puis j'ai réussi à ford a
tourné aussi ailleurs en europe et mal
on ne touche jamais allez donc c'est
plutôt cool pour moi d'avoir faire un
album bilingue comment vous appelez en
amérique
j'accueille ko béatrice martin
mais j'ai heureusement quelques chansons
en anglais parce que le célèbre blogueur
de los angeles perez hilton a dit nous
n'avons pas la moindre idée de ce dont
elle pas mais c'est adorable
en plus j'ai dessiné avec la la maison
10 de lady gaga de flèches de sting ah
ouais
et ça marche pour un 1 franchement vous
retourner à montréal quand même oui
j'habite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoutez de vente
m
[Musique]
grugger si tu nous regardes on t'attend
tu viens quand tu veux tu peux c'est par
exemple j'essaye
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis nulle accent chinois largement
parce qu'elle a l'accent canadien on
dirait c'est pas c'est un mélange de
suisse et
non parce que je sais pas on peut pas
faire comme si c'est s'était rien passé
alors coeur de pirate vous êtes un peu
la bad girl de la chanson québécoise en
même temps une bad girl au québec c'est
une fille qui est toutes les 10 de
céline dion à l'envers non ça c'est rare
mais sérieux adolescente vous traîniez
quand même avec pas mal de bad boy ça
c'est pour énerver votre mère mais vous
fréquentiez un peu le milieu hardcore
convainquons
des tatouages souvient de la taille un
peu de là je voulais appartenir à
quelque chose et ça c'est pas magnifique
temps à toi moi j'ai marqué maman aussi
je t'en as pas non parce que c'est trop
long
le plus dingue c'est que le mari de
coeur de pirate est à toi quand tu
imagines le mac en fait vous avez sa
chapelle sixtine d'une certaine le mec
s'exprime sur vous et surtout gratuit
vous rencontrez votre mari donc et à toi
comme l'émission est très discrète on
dira pas son nom ni rien on est
extrêmement discret
silva fait quand il dormait
et alors un mois après votre rencontre
avec le tatoueur vous tomber enceinte et
on a la photo du bébé
les dandys mais qu'est ce qu'on y gagne
car de pirates vous ne serez pas étonné
qu'on fasse une interview girl power
[Musique]
je concentré est-ce que vous avez déjà
dit non un mec super beau oui
moi j'ai rien fait
je vous ai déjà dit non à un mec célèbre
wii cinq minutes avant l'émission
julien doré
jeu
est-ce que vous avez déjà dit un mec que
c'était un super mauvais coup
ah oui ah oui
à mentir tous ces bois dans mon village
donc oui j'ai pas obligé de mentir mais
tu peux ne rien dire
comme ça comme des caches est-ce que
vous avez déjà donné de l'argent un mec
avec lequel vous aviez coucher
non pas encore
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez déjà chauffé un mec
à mort avant de partir oui
c'est intéressant froid qui a fait
vérité il le méritait voilà donc ce
avait prémédité façon le concernant
c'est ça veut dire gbocho fait autant
que je veux non c'est non est-ce que
vous avez déjà vu plus germain quand
même temps
au québec on a un truc qui s'appelle le
fréquenter en fait donc je sais pas
comment ça fonctionne en france mais si
on fréquente quelqu'un on peut voir
quelqu'un d'autre ou s'il en existe deux
dans la même journée
est-ce que vous avez déjà demandé un mec
de porter vos sous vêtements mais je
vais le faire
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez déjà affronté un
mec non non
[Musique]
on passe maintenant au dossier de la
semaine avec désintox et c'est victoria
liste de rmc et bfm tv daniel riolo que
nous accueillerons sur ce plateau après
le magnéto
désintox de ce soir l'euro sera tjrs est
un fiasco
[Musique]
du point de vue d'un djihadiste pour
reconnaître que l'euro 2016 c'est la
cible idéale d'abord la france est
l'ennemi absolu de dèche ensuite les
matchs pour se jouer dans dix dates
différentes il est ce que je vois des
objectifs et puis comme on attend 10
millions de supporters et de touristes
et aura forcément plein de gens
installés aux terrasses et surtout les
télés du monde entier seront présents
bref pour le dire cyniquement c'est
l'occasion idéale pour tous et un
maximum de gens en se faisant un maximum
de pub
vous la question faut-il annuler l'euro
2016 oh non ça serait ça serait une
défaite ce serait ça serait donner une
victoire aux terroristes il faut ces
manifestations sportives valve par le
français comme un camp de chasse et
joueur par les dégâts ce match contre
neige on va le gagner puis français sur
10 qui sont d'accord avec leur
entraîneur pas question d'annuler l'euro
2016 mais une fois dissipées ce moment
d'ivresse patriotique il y a vraiment de
quoi flipper très très fort c'est
mot-à-mot ce qu'a déclaré un membre des
services antiterroristes à l' agence
france-presse alors si même nos héros se
mettent à flipper doit-on s'inquiéter
prenons l'exemple des fans zone est ce
que c'est vraiment une bonne idée de
rassembler 100 mille personnes devant
des écrans géants tous les soirs pendant
un mois sous la tour eiffel l'ancien
directeur de la police nationale sous
sarkozy n'est pas vraiment pour che
offrir au terrorisme une possibilité de
faire un attentat massacre il faut
interdire les fans zone à paris mais
pour l'instant tout va bien il ya quinze
jours bernard cazeneuve a supervisé une
simulation d'attaqué alarme chimique
dans une fan zone anime tout s'est très
bien passé les 180 victimes ont été
évacuées dans des délais convenables
nous voulons que la fête soit belle et
pour que la fête soit belle il doit y
avoir zéro riesch sacrée bernard il nous
promet le risque zéro alors qu'il
reconnaît lui même que c'est impossible
mais même quand on veut prendre 100% de
précaution le risque zéro n'existe pas
la bonne nouvelle c'est que les normes
de sécurité dans les stades seront les
mêmes que dans les aéroports la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est qu'on a bien vu à
bruxelles que même les aéroports n'était
plus à l'abri d'un attentat
voilà c'était désintox mieux naco mise
en image de julien grappe à tous les
deux daniel riolo bonsoir vous avez du
cannabis chez rmc et bfm tv on vous
retrouve tous les soirs dans l'after
foot sur rmc bienvenue parmi nous en moi
je vous dis tout de suite ce ne sont pas
les attentats qui me font peur c'est
gignac attaquant des bleus n'ont
alors faut-il annuler l'euro 2016
hollande a dit il n'a jamais été
question de reporter ou supprimées
l'euro alors manuel valls est sur la
même ligne cazeneuve aussi caennais
rossi pareil pour les français
79% des français ne veulent pas qu'on
annule l'euro 2016 alors gilles verdez
lui propose des matches à huis clos sans
public vous en pensez quoi j'aime
beaucoup albert dess mais il a un défaut
c'est qu'il est prêt à dire n'importe
quoi pour se faire remarquer c'est pas
faux c'est un baby foot alors
non mais on peut faire un concert son
public ouais ça aux quinze ans il ya un
truc quand même daniel c'est que manuel
valls nous racontent toutes les semaines
on est en guerre on est en guerre on est
en guerre et de l'autre côté les gens
disent on veut continuer à vivre comme
avant si on est en guerre on peut plus
vivre comme avant mais on va pas vivre
exactement comme avant puisque je pense
qu'on va avoir une compétition ultra
sécurisé ultra-surveillé ça il faut s'y
préparer ça va être une compétition très
particulière de spoiler c'est clair est
la vigilance de tout le monde nous tous
qui allons voir des maquis faut faire
attention à tout ce qui se passe alors
faut-il au moins supprimer des fans zone
ça c'est un autre problème c'est un
petit peu ça ne rajeunit explique
parlant pour ma mère les fans zone c des
rassemblements de gens pour la tienne
aussi des cd rassemblement de gens
devant des écrans géants pardon ça pose
un problème pas seulement par seulement
lié au terrorisme
on sait aujourd'hui que toute
manifestation publique sur la voie
publique à paris ça part tout le temps
un petit peu en vrac y a toujours des
problèmes que soit une manifestation
syndicale ou même les étudiants qui
réussissent le bac voilà il ya toujours
ce genre de problème là ça va être très
difficile d'éviter à nouveau ses
problèmes mais ce que je veux bien
entendre en revanche c'est le discours
contenu certains politiques c'est que le
cou sécuritaire va être exorbitant je
peux concevoir que les riverains ont
neymar que ce soit cassée à côté de chez
eux et que ça coûte extrêmement cher de
les organiser l'euro 100% oui les fans
zone qu on ouvre sa la discussion ça je
veux bien je veux bien entendre non mais
c'est vrai qu'à la tour eiffel par
exemple et c'est ce que dit frédéric
péchenard un tour eiffel il va quand
même y avoir 100 mille personnes pour
les terroristes et une cible de choix
tout est une cible une école devient une
cible métro sera une cible donc là oui
effectivement il ya il ya énormément de
gens da cruz vient ici là on va parler
ballon on a maintenant benzema alors
est-ce que l'exemplarité pour un joueur
de foot c'est pas avant tout de marquer
des buts il s'agit pas forcément de
d'exemplarité moi je demande pas un
joueur de foot d'être exemplaire juste
de pas être mêlée à une embrouille à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu une embrouille
il est dedans et j'ai quand même du mal
à croire que ce soit le pierre richard
le football ça ne tombe pas dessus par
hasard on a chaque fois qu'il ya un truc
qui il est mêlé à ça donc là en
l'occurrence ça semble en plus quand
même un petit peu grave l'équipe de
france tourne bien sans lui justement
complètement sens parce que justement
est ce qu'après france-russie finalement
on peut pas se passer de valbuena
benzema fréquentes l'équipe de france
depuis 2008 c'est vrai ça faire un petit
peu je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse trouver
trace d'une personne qui va se souvenir
d'à quel moment benzema était le sauveur
de la nation où il a enflammé une soirée
où il a marqué un but capital mais je
trouve que c'est un joueur qui est
extraordinaire dans son club au real
madrid entouré d'autres stars il est
totalement épanouie mais en équipe de
france depuis 2008 20 je le répète il a
jamais été absolument décisif je vois
pas pourquoi on pourrait pas se passer
de karim benzema moi j'adore karim
benzema je trouve c'est vraiment un
excellent joueur et je trouve que ce
serait bien quand même qu'ils soient en
équipe de france ça arrête concilierait
beaucoup de choses parce que je ne mens
pas moi que ça va réconcilier puisque la
plupart des enquêtes qui sont quand même
fiables montrent que les français ont
plus envie de le voir en équipe de
france en tout cas voilà moi mon avis
personnel c'est que effectivement il n'a
pas fait grand chose dans l'équipe de
france mais quand même on aime voir
benzema en équipe de france qui va être
le grand leader des bleus parce que il
ya toujours un leader il ya eu copie il
platini et zidane qui va être dans
l'euro 2016 le grand leader des balaurs
on a c'est vrai qu'on a une tradition en
france à mettre un joueur comme ça en
avant vous ai cités kopa platini zidane
c'est un peu notre trio historique malik
ouais mais si on regarde les dernières
compétitions
l'espagne qui a brillé l'allemagne c'est
le collectif qui a été mis en avant
ouais donc je crois que les français ont
envie d'avoir une équipe fraîche
souriante on a envie de soutenir les
bleus à nouveau et on n'a pas forcément
avoir envie de revoir les visages qui
sont mêlés est certaine embrouille
benzema or équipe de france je pense que
les français sont pour puis valbuena le
pauvre il a complètement souffert de
cette affaire c'est quand même la
victime de cette affaire-là ce qui lui
arrive est absolument dégueulasse et
sportivement il pourra pas revenir parce
qu'il est hors du coup maintenant alors
coeur de pirate le mot de la fin
c'est un coup tu résumes pour que résume
en 20 minutes le football français lors
le monde et en maintenant l'économie
mondiale dominique strauss kahn tout ça
merci d'avoir des chiots on se retrouve
après la pub avec le japon qui ont
tous admis lenteur ce choix il a faim
est la plus menacée de france la
journaliste touchant bientôt tu dis là
[Musique]
alors mon soir l'ontarienne robe en soie
litterna sommes de retour sur terre
toujours en compagnie de victoria
brouille
[Applaudissements]
au coeur de pirate
heydari a du temps
et nous accueillons notre terrienne de
samedi 20h ce soir zineb el rhazoui
bonjour
journaliste à charlie hebdo vous avez
échappé au massacre du 7 janvier 2015
depuis les islamistes du monde entier
ont fait de vous leur cible numéro un et
vous êtes aujourd'hui la femme la plus
menacée donc la plus protégée de france
on vous retrouve à 20 heures voilà alors
dans un instant stéphane guillon mais
d'abord le zapping
c'était le zapping jusqu'ici tout allait
bien voici stéphane guillon le best-of
on commence avec une bonne nouvelle
alain finkielkraut reçu en séance
solennelle à l'académie française pour
l'occasion les immortels ont remis au
philosophe son habit vert et son épée
remettent une épée à finkielkraut
c'est pas très prudent
je tiens avant tout à remercier mes
pairs les 39 immortels de l'académie
française pour la confiance et l'honneur
qu'il me faut grâce à cette épée un
moment sa pierre je n'aurai de cesse de
défendre la langue de molière de
ferraille et transpercer porter
l'estocade occire
picot maltraitera l'orthographe
brutalise râle verbe et rue noire à la
grammaire taisez vous
lors de sa visite en polynésie françois
hollande a promis d'installer un
distributeur de billets de banque sur
l'archipel de futuna un beau cadeau pour
réparer apaiser la douleur des familles
empoisonné par les 193 essais nucléaires
français
[Musique]
le bilan est catastrophique
9000 personnes atteintes de leucémie ou
de cancer de la thyroïde suite à nos
essais
même s'il n'est pas question de tout les
indemniser j'ai voulu faire un geste
fort
l'installation d'un distributeur
automatique
pour permettre aux polynésiens malades
de payer le chignon
la france ne doit pas pour autant
demander pardon je vois à quel point
vous savez tisser les couronnes de
fleurs je me dit que pour fleurir les
victimes des essais français c'était la
région idéale vous êtes encore meilleur
qu'un père florent
maintenant accuse les ennemis
lors de son voyage à new york alain
juppé a dormi au sofitel dans la même
seconde que dsk l'a 28 06 à mon avis
l'hôtel a immédiatement appelé sarkozy
monsieur sarkozy bonjour c'est le
directeur du sofitel de new york à
l'appareil dites moi je vous appelle
parce qu'on a de nouveau un de vos
concurrents à la batterie 0,6 oui - oui
oui
monsieur juppé on fait comme la dernière
fois j'en vois une femme de chambre
normale en lui faisant croire que c'est
une [__]
ah d'accord ça sert à rien il a aucun
vice alcool drogues bondage rien bon je
lui montre le figaro une tasse de thé
désolé de ne pas pouvoir vous aider plus
monsieur sarkozy bon courage 100 kg où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
six personnes qui s'apprêtaient à partir
en syrie pour faire le jihad ont été
arrêtés alors qu'elle projetait
d'attaquer des clubs libertins
dsk a souhaité réagir
[Applaudissements]
je me sens menacé tiers des sombres
pourquoi pas les bars les salles de
spectacles des clubs sont visés la
caverne venus les chandelles le cupidon
le diablotin et lieu de communion où
chacun donne ce soir change de position
le point de vue il faut protéger ses
recoins car les sourds les alcôves ses
banquettes ces coussins ses poufs
ces pauvres
les membres sont vulnérables dévêtue
ébranlé menottée ou entravée par des
étriers déchirée par des spéculoos et
passat et on en cas de danger coincé par
an par derrière
demoiselle ne peut pas crier sa bouche
est prise
si elle crie elle de la peur du plaisir
ne sais pas
plongée dans l'obscurité le voir comment
distinguer la cagoule d'un djihadiste
avec celle d'un catcheur sado-maso
faut réagir et aller son héros ce héros
c'est en danger a trop dit tu as peur
à la semaine prochaine
à lyon qu'on retrouve ici la semaine
prochaine sur canal + et au théâtre
dejazet on fasse maintenant à notre
matériel du samedi matin
zineb el rhazoui rebond soir vous étiez
le 19 janvier 1982 à casablanca au maroc
père mécanicien à la royal air maroc
mère femme au foyer votre mère était
métis la métisse aux yeux bleus
magnifiques familles de la classe
moyenne marocaine on a le culte de la
lecture dans votre famille votre père
est ce qu'on appelle un musulman de
gauche mais à l'époque la religion n'est
pas une question qui se pose en fait ce
n'est pas une question qui se pose mais
ce n'est pas non plus quelque chose dont
on a le choix puisque c'est une
théocratie et qu'on a des cours de
religion obligatoire à l'école vous fait
15 ans d'éducation religieuse à l'école
quand même vous dites je connais l'islam
mieux que les frères koichi ça j'en suis
à peu près certaine
j'ai étudié l'islam disons de la
maternelle jusqu'au bac et pg continuer
de façon facultative plus tard des
études d'islamologie et de sociologie
des régions
après le bac 1 sorbonne vous étudiez
dites-vous pleinement la non existence
de dieu
c'était déjà arrivé à cette conclusion
avant sauf que ce n'était pas légale de
le penser au maroc j'ai pu le vivre
pleinement une fois qu'il a été en
france alors vous commencé à militer au
maroc avec le pique nique des des
jeûneurs ainsi des gens qui refusent de
jeûner pendant ramadan proteste surtout
contre l'article 222 du code pénal
marocain qui vous qui vaut jeu jusqu'à
six mois de prison si vous mangez en
public away ou vous buvez de l'eau ah
ouais dolomie ça c'est chaud là vous
écopez de votre première fatwa ça sera
pas la dernière alors fin 2011 harcelé
par la police marocaine vous exiler en
slovénie puis en france où vous devenez
porte-parole de ni [__] ni soumises
voilà en 2013 il est embauché comme
journaliste à charlie hebdo ce qu'il
faut dire au sujet de charlie hebdo
c'est qu'en 2006 il ya vu la publication
des caricatures de mahomet et en 2011
lincendie du journal donc quand vous
arrivez en fait il ya déjà une
protection policière sur chab et sur
d'autres collaborateurs de charlie sur
les locaux et en tout cas il y avait
déjà pléthore de fatwas et toute la
kabbale de l'opinion publique contre
charlie hebdo et ses dessinateurs alors
pour ne rien arranger en février 2013 ou
publier une bande dessinée les sharks
qui s'appelle la ville mahomet et la
nouvelle fatwa le mercredi 7 janvier
2015 les frères kwasi assassine
froidement huit membres de la rédaction
deux policiers un employé la sodexo est
un journaliste qui était invité vous
vous êtes au maroc en vacances en fait
j'ai j'y étais depuis les fêtes de fin
d'année je me tâte et cette semaine là
je rentre ou pas finalement je me suis
réveillée tôt j'ai envoyé un mail à char
pour proposer mon papier à distance et
je n'ai jamais eu sa réponse
le numéro des survivants va se vendre à
8 millions d'exemplaires et gêné et 12
millions d'euros de recettes là vous
passez de la protection à la haute
protection
sur les réseaux sociaux des chaires
extrémistes on voit les textes genre si
vous n'avez pas d'armes isolé là dans
une pièce et fracassé lui le crâne avec
une pierre tranchées lui la gorge ou
brûler sa maison exact c'était de
hashtag le premier disait obligation de
tuer la belle rase motte pour venger le
prophète et le second disait localiser
des bellrays oui pour la tuer ça a été
partagée selon la presse plus de 7500
joie sur twitter
alors évidemment la haine est multipliée
parce que vous êtes une femme d'origine
musulmane
qui critiquent l'islam en cause jean de
cause en plus exact quand je parle je
parle avec des versets des hadiths des
sourates jeu et en plus j'ai vécu la
majeure partie de ma vie en théocratie
islamique donc je sais ce que c'est que
quand l'islam régit la cité en fait là
vous devenez la femme la plus menacée et
donc la plus protégée de france est
votre seul loisir en fait c'est d'aller
au stand de tir avec vos gardes du corps
disons que c'est pas vraiment un loisir
j'espère ne jamais avoir à toucher des
armes je pense que les armes devraient
être réservés aux professionnels
mais c'était occasion vu que maintenant
j'en suis entouré c'était juste pour en
faire la découverte quelques mois après
les attentats
l'ambiance devient irrespirable à
charlie hebdo
d'un côté il ya les deux actionnaires
survivants rice et eric porto le
directeur financier et de l'autre côté
bas un collectif de salariés
et vous déclarer tout cet argent c'est à
dire 12 millions d'euros ce n'est pas un
retour sur investissement c'est le sens
des morts nous considérons avec un
ensemble de collègues acharné d'eau que
cet argent n'est pas quelque chose ce
qui devrait enrichir les actionnaires
mais qui devrait surtout profiter à la
pérennité du journal et eau et aux
victimes aussi bien sûr alors là les
charlie veulent vous vrai il ya une
levée de boucliers incroyable et la
procédure est annulée exactement c'est à
dire on a commencé une procédure ou m'a
donné une lettre de convocation à un
entretien préalable à licenciement pour
une faute grave qu'on m'a pas expliqué
et quand il ya eu cette levée de
boucliers en gros on m'a dit non non tu
as fait une caméra cachée en fait voilà
alors après les attentats du 13 novembre
vous appelez un état d'urgence
idéologique vous dites les frappes
aériennes en syrie et en irak ne
régleront pas le problème il faut
s'attaquer à la chaîne de production
idéologique
il faut arrêter d'être pris en otage par
le chantage au racisme et à
l'islamophobie donc ça c'est le coeur du
problème sur ce que vous dites en gros
c'est que pour pas être raciste pour
être islamophobe les français ont
accepté beaucoup de choses et
aujourd'hui se rendent compte qu'ils ont
eu tort ils ont été victimes d'une
idéologie bisounours exactement et c'est
cette idéologie d'ailleurs selon moi
continue racisme c'est à dire que l'on
refuse à la culture ou la civilisation
islamique de faire son aggiornamento ça
dort on refuse à ces intellectuels de la
critique et de toute personne qui
critiquent cette idéologie est taxé
d'islamophobe sous-entendu racistes
alors qu'une personne qui critiqueraient
le clip du christianisme ne seraient pas
taxées de christianophobes donc
prétendument raciste anti occidentaux et
puis je trouve aussi que c'est un
discours qui nuit à la fois à à
l'universalisme auquel temps une partie
des musulmans et aussi à l'antiracisme
qui devrait être amené à ce qu'il est
c'est-à-dire discrimination à l'embauché
sur le faciès discrimination au logement
etc et non pas acceptation de choses qui
sont qui violent nos lois acceptation de
de gens en burqa et avec des barbes
jusqu'ici qui veulent le faire des
exceptions à la loi française au nom de
l'acceptation de l'autre vous dites je
suis contre l'islam car l'islam est
contre moi et c'est vrai qu'en tant que
femme dans l'islam que j'étais inférieur
je ne vaux rien je vole à moitié d'un
homme mon témoignage ci j'assiste à un
crime
faute de témoignages de femmes pour
valoir le témoignage d'un homme j'évite
la moitié alors que l'éditeur rien par
exemple au maroc les femmes héritent de
la moitié même en tunisie sains et où il
n'y a pas un seul pays où l'islam est
force de loi ou les femmes évitent à
égalité avec les hommes alors vous
publiez 13 aux éditions ring c'est un
livre témoignage sur les attentats
évidemment du 13 novembre
dans la préface du premier position très
claire contre la bien pensante en france
par exemple en france quand il ya un
attentat comme ça la première parole des
pouvoirs publics c'est à dire attention
pas d' amalgame une fois quelqu'un m'a
dit sur un plateau avec énormément de
condescendance il y à un milliard de
musulmans sur le monde dans le monde
vous pensez vraiment que ce sont tous
des terroristes
d'abord personne n'a prétendu ça il faut
être extrêmement bête pour le dire en
revanche on peut se poser la question
pourquoi est ce que depuis un certain
temps france tous les attentats qui ont
été commis récemment ont été commis par
des gens qui se proclamer comme musulman
qui l'ont fait au nom de l'islam et qui
surtout ce sont des textes qui incite au
djihad françois hollande par exemple
quand il ya des attentats il dit oui ce
sont pas des musulmans ce sont des
criminels que cela ne pouvait pas être
les deux à la fois alors quel est votre
vie aujourd'hui de femme la plus menacée
donc la plus protégée de france comment
vous arrivez à vivre et bien tout
d'abord moi même si je suis dans une
prison ambulante je je je
j'ai là j'ai le sentiment d'être
beaucoup plus libre que ce qui me qui
veulent ma peau parce que la prison ils
ont à l'intérieur de leur crâne donc je
continue à vivre je voyage je sors je
voir mes amis
évidemment avec énormément de logistique
autour il le faut il ya aussi parfois
une renonciation à certaines choses mais
rien n'égale la liberté de pensée en
fait
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes en simple
ça veut dire que vous y croyez encore à
bien sûr quel que soit le totalitarisme
auxquels on fait face que ce soit les
islamistes ou une dictature il ne faut
jamais faire le plaisir à ses
adversaires de cesser de vivre ne cessez
de profiter de la vie
bravo pour votre courage
[Applaudissements]
voire c'est un salut les terriens votre
taux du samedi soir avec
victoria
coeur de
paris
daniel
et zineb el rhazoui merci beaucoup merci
le matin
je vous rappelle que le sidaction c'est
ce week-end pour faire vos dons un seul
numéro le 110 ou un seul site
sidaction.org
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu de
bleu